ahora vamos a ver cómo nombrar aldehídos
y cetonas vamos a empezar con un
aldehído y para refrescar la memoria
acerca de cómo reconocer aldehídos aquí
tenemos un grupo carbón y lo que es un
carbono con un doble enlace a un oxígeno
y luego de un lado tenemos un grupo
alquilo una cadena de carbonos y del
otro lado tenemos simplemente un
hidrógeno por otro lado si quisiéramos
ponerle un nombre a esta molécula
extremadamente sencilla entonces a ver
aquí tenemos un carbono dos tres cuatro
carbonos entonces usamos el prefijo
wooten
y es un arcano entonces butano por otro
lado si quisiéramos ponerle el nombre a
un aldehído de 4 carbono lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es ponerle el número 1
al carbono del carbón y lo aunque este
es el carbono número 12
4 entonces tenemos una leído de 4
carbonos y lo que vamos a hacer es
quitar la o del final y sustituirla por
el de aldehído aunque entonces nos queda
gusten al una leído de 4 carbonos shvut
en 'la pero bueno vamos a ver otros
ejemplos
y hay que recordar siempre vamos a
empezar a enumerar de tal forma que el
carbono del grupo carbón hilo en el
menor número de carbono posible y el
aldehído va a tener prioridad sobre
cosas como enlaces dobles grupos alc y
los halógenos entonces pues vamos con
este al de youtube aquí arriba y otra
vez tenemos que enumerar a estos
carbonos de tal forma que el carbono del
grupo carbón y lo tenga el menor número
posible entonces pues este carbono de
aquí es el 12
4 y 5 si tuviéramos un arcano de 5
carbonos eso sería un 30 no pero como es
un aldehído lo que tenemos es un
ventanal
ahora no sólo es un ventanal también
tenemos un sustituye ente en el carbono
número 4
tenemos un bromo esta molécula se llama
4 bromo
bromo ventanal bueno ahora vamos con
este al tejido por aquí y empezamos a
enumerar los carbonos de tal forma que
el carbono del grupo carbón y lotes en
el menor número posible entonces este es
el carbono número 12
así es que tenemos un el de ido con 3
carbono y un aldehído con 3 carbonos se
llama pro panal pero este ha leído
además tiene un enlace doble entonces
ahora se llama pro penal
p
y además este enlace doble empieza en el
carbono número 2 sería un 2 pro penal y
además tiene un grupo de nilo en el
carbono número 3 así es que se llama 3
senil
en mil dos pero penal y si quieres
especificar la exterior química del
enlace doble pues puedes pensar en dónde
están los hidrógenos aquí tenemos estos
dos hidrógenos y así cuando piensas
acerca de este enlace doble de aquí los
hidrógenos están en lados opuestos por
lo que podemos decir que se trata de una
molécula trans o podemos usar el sistema
zeta y nuestros grupos de mayor
prioridad están en lados opuestos por lo
que el sistema nos dice que se trata de
una e
entonces una forma de llamarle a esta
molécula es 3 fenil 2 pro penal pero si
queremos utilizar una forma más moderna
de llamarle a esta molécula escribimos
y después tenemos este grupo fein y lo
en el carbono número 3 entonces ponemos
3 genil
y en la nueva forma primero pondríamos
pero
después del 22
y finalmente la terminación a él a él de
aldehído ok aquí el 2 al lado del n nos
está indicando que el enlace doble
empieza en el carbono número 2 ahí se me
olvidó poner estos paréntesis por aquí
ambos son nombres adecuados según el
sistema de nomenclatura iupac para esta
molécula que se llama comúnmente sinama
aldehído
sin él
al té ido
qué es la molécula que hace que la
canela huela de la forma en la que huele
tiene un olor fantástico y la puedes
destilar del vapor y aislar esta
molécula lo cual sería una excelente
práctica de laboratorio de química
orgánica de la licenciatura que ella es
la sina maldecida por otro lado por aquí
tenemos otro balde ido que huele súper
bien que se llama ven sal de ido
ven
d
dense aldehído que es un nombre tan
común que se incorporó al sistema de
nomenclatura iupac y éste benzal de ido
huele como las nueces por aquí tenemos
otro compuesto que huele súper bien por
lo que las prácticas de laboratorio que
incluyen derivados del bne sal de ido
resultan ser muy divertidas y si ves
algo en sal de ido en alguna de sus
moléculas puedes utilizarlo dentro de la
nomenclatura aunque por ejemplo aquí
esto es un benzal de ido
ven
d
este es el pensar de ido y queremos
numerar sus carbonos empezando a partir
de este carbono entonces este es el
carbono número un nuevo y podemos seguir
enumerando en el sentido de las
manecillas o en contra del sentido de
las manecillas pero para hacer que estos
substituyen tes tengan el menor número
posible tenemos que seguir el sentido de
las manecillas entonces este es el
carbono 2
y 4 así es que tenemos un sustituyen te
meto cxi en el carbono número 3 y un
substituyen te hidroxi en el carbono
número 4 tenemos que ordenar estos
sustituye entes en el orden alfabético y
la h está antes en el alfabeto que la m
entonces esto es 4 hidroxi
hidroxi 3
stokes y
talks y dense aldehído y este es el
nombre sistemático iupac de un compuesto
que se llama bunny lina bunny
también conocido como vainillina que es
la molécula que le da el olor a la
vainilla y también el sabor que tiene un
fantástico olor y sabor la band y línea
que son estos cristales blancos que
tienen un padrísimo olor a vainilla y
por lo tanto también es muy divertido
hacer experimentos de laboratorio con
ellos muy bien entonces muchísimos
aldehídos tienen un muy buen olor y
vamos a ver otros dos aldehídos entonces
empezamos con esta molécula de aquí ojo
este no es un ven sal de ido porque no
tenemos aquí un anillo vencen y ccoo lo
que tenemos aquí es un ciclo hexano
y lo externo
carval de ido gay karp
y bueno entonces vamos con esta molécula
en esta molécula tenemos dos grupos
aldehídos porque la terminación va a ser
de 'la y tenemos una cadena de carbonos
de 1 2 3 4 5 carbonos entonces esta
molécula se llama ventana
no vi al vi
también queremos indicar dónde están
nuestros 2 aldehídos los cuales están en
el carbono 1 y el carbono 5 entonces
ponemos por aquí 15 ventana vial y
entonces ahora vamos a ver nomenclatura
de la acetona
y para recordar rápidamente lo que son
los aceptan es tenemos aquí un grupo
carbón y lo grupo carbón hilo y dos
grupos al kilos donde estos dos grupos
no necesariamente tienen que ser iguales
que hay aquí podríamos poner el reprime
y esto sigue siendo un acetona por aquí
tenemos una cadena de 4 carbonos
igualita a la que teníamos al principio
de este vídeo y esta molécula se llama
butano
ahora qué pasa si tenemos una acetona de
4 carbonos y aquí tenemos el carbono 1 2
3 4 y entonces lo que hacemos para
nombrar a esta molécula es quitar la o
del nombre de esta molécula y entonces
tenemos butano y le ponemos la
terminación de la acetona que es o n
bután o nada
aunque bueno tal vez no era necesario
quitar lado y simplemente agregar la n a
pero bueno el chiste es que esto de una
se refiere a un aceptan a este es el
nombre you back' de esta molécula pero
también se le puede llamar de otra forma
de acuerdo al sistema de nomenclatura
iupac la forma vieja de llamarle a las c
tonadas pero que de todas formas que lo
puedes encontrar por ahí es fijarte en
los grupos al kilos de la acetona aunque
por aquí tenemos un grupo metilo y por
aquí tenemos un grupo estilo entonces la
forma vieja de llamarle a las personas
es ponerme till
metil y luego útil
y finalmente se torna se zona y bueno la
va antes que la m en el abecedario
entonces tal vez debería haberlo llamado
útil metí el set o no pero esta molécula
en particular es súper conocida como
metil etil cetona y se abrevia m&c pero
bueno vamos con otras dos zonas que
están por aquí
ahora queremos ponerle el nombre a esta
zona de aquí aunque es una zona un poco
más larga vamos a enumerar a los
carbonos de esta cadena pero haciéndolo
de tal forma que el carbono del grupo
carbón y lo tenga el menor número
posible entonces tenemos que empezar por
aquí
este es el carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
así es que aquí tenemos un examen
hola
sin embargo todavía no hemos terminado
también tenemos que indicar dónde está
el grupo carbón y lo entonces tenemos
que poner por aquí tres ex zanon aunque
pero esta es la forma antigua de nombrar
a estos detona la forma actual nos dice
que tenemos que poner examen
ex y después el 3
y finalmente la terminación o n ii y n
para indicar que el grupo carbón hilo se
encuentra en el carbono número 3 ahora
la forma utilizando los grupos al kilos
de nombrar a esta molécula es decir aquí
tenemos un grupo estilo y aquí tenemos
un grupo pro pilot entonces esta
molécula es un reptil útil profil
pero bill y es una aceptan a ser
zona y eso de que sea una acetona es
algo que tiene más prioridad que los
enlaces dobles y los grupos al kilos y
los halógenos y esas cosas entonces
vamos a empezar a enumerar esta cadena
de carbonos de tal forma que el grupo
carbón y lo tenga el menor número
posible entonces empezamos a numerar por
aquí
este es el carbono número 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
así es que tenemos una acetona de 6
carbonos eso sería una examen normal
pero aquí tenemos un enlace doble
entonces más bien tenemos una exceso es
el nombre base y bueno hay dos formas de
llamarle a esta molécula una es poner
primero excel
exc y después indicar que el grupo
carbón y lo está en el carbono número 22
y finalmente la terminación una corona
este 2 va con horna indicando dónde está
el grupo carbón y lo y después para
indicar dónde está el doble enlace
ponemos por aquí un 4 ex en una y bueno
pues esta es la forma vieja de llamarle
a esta molécula la forma nueva sería
poner
y después un 4 después en n n y así el 4
y luego la n están indicando que el
doble enlace empieza en el carbono
número 4 y después otra vez 21 y luego
nos ponemos a pensar en la exterior
química del doble enlace y aquí tenemos
un hidrógeno y por aquí tenemos otro
hidrógeno estos hidrógenos están en
lados opuestos por lo que tenemos una
molécula trans o también podemos decir
que tenemos una molécula
entonces ponemos por aquí
4 exentos una o también podemos decir
cuatro en dos una ahora vamos a ver
otros dos ejemplos tenemos por aquí un
grupo carbón hilo en un ciclo este ciclo
sería un hexano pero como es una aceptó
na entonces se llama ciclohexano na
ciclo
no tenemos también aquí un grupo alquiló
pero el grupo carbón y lo tiene
prioridad sobre los grupos al kilos
entonces empezamos a enumerar los
carbonos a partir de este carbono este
es el carbono 1 y luego para que el
grupo el kilo tenga el menor número de
carbono posible vamos a enumerar en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj
entonces este es el carbono 2
3 así es que tenemos un grupo metilo en
el carbono número 3
eso es 3 metil etil ciclo hexano la y
este es un nombre de acuerdo al sistema
upac ahora vamos por aquí qué pasa si
tenemos dos cetonas de esta forma pues
lo que va a pasar es que vamos a tener
una terminación de una mujer y empezamos
a numerar la cadena de carbonos de tal
forma que tengan el menor número de
carbono posible entonces este es el
carbono 12
4 5 y 6 y otra vez hay dos formas de
llamarle a esta molécula la vieja y la
nueva podríamos poner el sano y eso
simplemente nos está diciendo que
tenemos aquí una cadena de 6 carbonos y
después ponemos de una indicando que
tenemos dos grupos carbón y los dos
cetonas y al principio ponemos los
carbonos en los que están estos grupos
carbón y los que son el 2 y el 4 24
hexano diona pero la forma más moderna
de llamarle a esta molécula es poner
primero hexano hexano después los
números 24 24 indicando dónde están los
grupos carbón y los y después de onna
y eso es todo acerca de la nomenclatura
de los aldehídos y las zonas